[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia afecta a los cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de hacinamiento o
de marginalidad o se veían obligadas a
migrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo comenzamos en el sudeste
asiático los cierres de las escuelas en
indonesia dejaron desde marzo a millones
de jóvenes sin acceso a la educación
porque en este país sólo 1 de cada 6
hogares tiene conexión a internet pero
desde hace dos meses un grupo de
voluntarios encontró la solución los
estudiantes
reciclan plástico para intercambiarlo
por este servicio por internet además un
grupo de personas se encarga de
transportar el transmisor de red para
llevar la red de wifi hasta las zonas
más remotas de yakarta la capital de
indonesia veamos el informe de mar y
aclara calle
recoger botellas de plástico esto es lo
que hace de masa noir pura para estudiar
por internet el joven de 15 años sale a
las calles de un barrio popular de
yakarta indonesia junto con sus amigos
lo que recolectan lo llevan a la
estación wifi allí incluso leahy meter
uno de los directivos del banco de
residuos de coia les recibe el plástico
para venderlo con ese dinero compra
datos de internet para que los jóvenes
puedan estudiar con 340 mil rupias que
equivalen a 22 dólares un grupo pequeño
de estudiantes tiene conexión wifi
durante todo un mes así un kilo de
plástico les garantiza 9 horas de clase
a la semana
para lo que está
y recolectamos basura es como una obra
de caridad para mí y aparte de eso
también obtenemos datos gratuitos para
tan grandes el siguiente paso viene con
los llamados voluntarios escolares ellos
se encargan de llevar la conexión con un
transmisor de red que transportan en
este automóvil su destino las aldeas
remotas del sur de yakarta
esta agua de tu cama comenzamos a este
servicio al principio porque el gobierno
había decidido que los estudiantes
deberían aprender en línea y escuchamos
quejas de los estudiantes especialmente
de aquellos que viven en áreas remotas
para por la mañana colgar crujan de
playa a playa cosechan liderazgo así que
se nos ocurrió la idea de ayudar a los
niños en las aldeas y es por eso que
creamos el wifi móvil de allianz y pozo
de datos interesa mucho el idioma maya
lin
además de llevar la red de wifi los
voluntarios les prestan computadoras
portátiles y teléfonos móviles a los
jóvenes para que se conecten a las
sesiones virtuales de su escuela
sobre tanga para el problema de aprender
online es que rara vez usó el celular
para para su carne pegada más
compartamos móvil con mis padres y a
veces ellos no están en casa tanto
ayudas o que llegan en europa ahora la
solución para rafa y otros jóvenes son
los móviles de los voluntarios escolares
y así vuelven a clase
viajemos a nigeria donde pasa algo
similar a lo de indonesia desde que en
marzo de 2020 la pandemia de coronavirus
irrumpió en este país del áfrica
occidental los colegios y las escuelas
cerraron se trata del país del mundo que
cuenta la mayor cantidad de niños que se
han quedado sin educación una cifra que
ronda los 13 millones de acuerdo con la
organización de las naciones unidas pero
la situación es aún más grave para los
estudiantes de los barrios marginales y
las comunidades más pobres para llenar
ese vacío organizaciones de caridad han
lanzado programas de ayuda que incluyen
la donación de tabletas digitales y
computadores para impulsar el
aprendizaje a distancia
afuera de su casa en lagos en el barrio
marginal de ma coco esther y que chuck
muy improvisa un pupitre con algunos
perros encima dispone una tableta
digital se ubica un audífono con
auricular media está todo listo para que
esta joven de 17 años tome clase a
distancia el hecho es que extraño la
escuela pero lo que me está haciendo en
este momento del programa es que no me
hace perder las clases y de esta manera
no me estoy atravesando como esther
alrededor de mil niños están aprendiendo
a distancia gracias a una organización
llamada slam school algo parecido a de
los barrios bajos a la escuela el
programa cuenta con 30 profesores que
vía online tienen el objetivo de
impactar a 10.000 estudiantes para el
final de año
por medio de los barrios bajos a la
escuela la mayoría de mis amigos ahora
están estudiando y están mucho mejor de
lo que estaban antes ya no son esa clase
de personas que solían ser
pero las condiciones para esther suelen
ser adversas poca electricidad para
cargar su tableta digital y una señal de
internet intermitente problemas
detectados por la organización de los
barrios bajos a la escuela de manera que
ya han dispuesto paneles solares y otras
fuentes de energía
y hemos tenido conversaciones sobre la
realidad de más de 13 millones de niños
que no van a la escuela en nigeria no
necesariamente tenemos que esperar hasta
que haya un salón de clases para
ubicarlos esos niños todavía pueden
aprender en su comodidad a través del
programa de aprendizaje en grupo según
el fundador de esta organización el
hecho de no estar yendo a clases
presenciales ha expuesto a los niños y
jóvenes de escasos recursos a
situaciones de trabajo prematuro para
apoyar a sus familias pero en julio con
la entrega de dispositivos electrónicos
para el barrio marginal de ma coco en la
capital de nigeria las familias dejaron
de tener excusas para permitir el
aprendizaje de sus hijos y así
blindarlos con educación para el futuro
continuamos en áfrica pero con una
problemática de salud en sudán una
enfermedad contraída en el campo se le
está conociendo como la muerte
silenciosa científicamente su nombre es
mi se toma y ha llegado al centro de
investigaciones de jartúm la capital
sudanesa para ser estudiada porque sus
víctimas pueden pasar hasta una
con la dolencia antes de morir se trata
de una enfermedad contraída por la
picadura de una espina y que de acuerdo
con la organización mundial de la salud
afecta a las personas de las comunidades
más vulnerables
cádillac matt estaba plantando cebollas
en darfur una región occidental de sudán
cuando pisó una espina que atravesó su
sandalia sin saberlo cadilla se
convertiría en una víctima de un 1000 se
toma no se trata de una enfermedad
mortal apenas 5% de los casos llegan a
la muerte pero de no tratarse a tiempo
las personas infectadas pueden sufrir
malformaciones o amputaciones así le
pasó a cadilla 9 años después de haber
pisado la espina me dolía mucho en mi
pie estaba muy hinchado tiene que el
hospital y me sacaron el museo donde
después me operaron y me amputaron la
pierna en el andén está el caso de cádiz
ya es común en esta región de sudán al
vivir en zonas rurales evitan visitar el
médico por el transporte que conlleva
para cadilla sólo se trataba de un
pequeño bulto que iba creciendo con los
años pero no pensaba que le costaría su
pierna la enfermedad afecta a los más
pobres en las comunidades remotas son
pacientes con un nivel socioeconómico
bajo así como un bajo nivel
educación en salud por tanto se
presentan tardíamente cuando la
enfermedad está en etapa avanzada
de acuerdo con las clasificaciones de la
organización mundial de la salud el mí
se toma es una de las enfermedades
tropicales desatendidas es decir que los
gobiernos no realizan campañas de
concienciación para que la ciudadanía
prevenga fatalidades seguimos hablando
de salud en eeuu los jóvenes y
especialmente aquellos pertenecientes a
las minorías étnicas son más vulnerables
al cob y 19 así lo afirma un reciente
informe de los centros para el control y
la prevención de enfermedades hasta la
fecha eeuu es el país con más contagios
en el mundo contabilizando más de
6.600.000 contagios y cerca de 200.000
muertes en cuanto a las muertes
asociadas a personas menores de 21 años
de febrero a julio
los cdc estimaron que el 78 por ciento
son de grupos étnicos minoritarios
específicamente el 45 por ciento de
hispanos el 29 por ciento de
afroamericanos y el 4 por ciento de
indígenas estadounidenses o nativos de
alaska
continúa la pesadilla de miles de
refugiados en las islas griegas después
del incendio en el campo de moria ahora
los refugiados rechazan ingresar al
nuevo campamento provisional ante la
falta de garantías mientras las
autoridades griegas están intentando
persuadirlos alegando que es un
requisito para la posibilidad de
tramitar las solicitudes de asilo este
martes las autoridades arrestaron a
cinco migrantes señalados de ser
responsables de haber iniciado el
incendio el primer ministro griego se
reunió con el presidente de la comisión
europea haciendo un llamado a la
solidaridad comunitaria marina sardinia
amplia en el siguiente informe
bajo la disyuntiva de permanecer
durmiendo a la intemperie o ingresar
bajo coacción al nuevo campamento de
karate así se encuentran miles de
refugiados varados en la isla de lesbos
casi una semana después del incendio que
arrasó con moria el mayor campo de
refugiados de europa el 15 de septiembre
las autoridades griegas detuvieron a
cinco migrantes por su presunta
implicación en el siniestro el llamado
de quienes dormían en el campamento es
que no lo señalen a todos
han pasado diez meses desde que estoy
aquí en grecia las condiciones de vida
son más duras que en afganistán hay
muchos problemas de vida no sólo para mí
sino también para otros migrantes cuando
alguien hace algo malo aquí al resto no
lo deberían tratar como culpable espero
que esto no suceda porque un solo
migrante malo no puede representar a
todos los migrantes
sí
en las inmediaciones de moria los
refugiados se rehúsan a ingresar en el
nuevo campamento las autoridades griegas
intentan persuadirlos con folletos
informativos pues aseguran que su
entrada al campo transitorio es la única
vía para solicitar eso allí es el
infierno número dos yo ya estaba en la
cárcel porque estar en memoria es estar
en la cárcel aplicó así que vengo aquí y
veo gente coches entrando no no quiero
entrar
más que otro campamento temporal los
migrantes quieren que les den asilo de
una vez por todas en suelo europeo y
alemania ya respondió al llamado las
autoridades germanas anunciaron que
acogerán a mil 553 refugiados incluidos
150 menores no acompañados
esto contribuirá en general al hecho de
que el impulso para una solución se ha
incrementado que esta realidad está
lejos de terminar así que debe continuar
el esfuerzo con eso porque también
queremos que toda europa actúe en bloque
en este ámbito por eso también es
importante que digamos que lo haremos en
cualquier caso y que estamos preparados
para desarrollar y apoyar
el gobierno griego también hizo un
llamado a la solidaridad del bloque
europeo mientras que los migrantes
esperan una respuesta al abandono
institucional que han padecido durante
años
este es el panorama en educación salud y
derechos humanos de las personas más
vulnerables esta semana en el mundo a
ustedes gracias por seguirnos recuerden
que más información la pueden encontrar
en nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]